I just wouldn't be the holidays without  a little holiday music so without  further ado here to perform yet another  updated version of the controversial  classic baby it's cold outside  please welcome from their Duluth  Minnesota tryout of America's Got Talent  Mitchell Andy you know the holidays are  fun and all but sometimes they can get  pretty boozy and when people get boozy  they get handsy and often ignore signs  that the other person may just want to  leave and that can lead to lawsuits  believe me I know  so here's a little ditty about a safe  way everyone can enjoy the holidays I  [Music]  want to see you but baby it's snowing  outside plus you live really far it'd  have to defrost your car and I'm already  buzzed yeah I've had some drinks too  pluses 12:26  yeah it's getting real late so we should  just stay home  [Music]  [Applause]  we do we can do it together on FaceTime  hey that's a great idea  [Applause]  [Applause]